so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone i'm ryozo tsujimoto producer
on the monster hunter series hello i'm
yoshitake suzuki director of monster
hunter rise sun break
it's been a month since the game's
release and we're happy to see so many
people enjoying the game thank you very
much
we've received a lot of feedback from
the fans and the entire dev team is very
thankful for that this has made us extra
motivated to work on the updates
speaking of which today we are here to
tell you
about free title update 1 version 11.
first let's have a look at this trailer
enjoy
here
be careful
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
the t sure does take the edge off
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you're mine
[Music]
free title update 1 version 11 for
monster hunter rise sun break
will release on august 10th
today we'll go into more detail about
this free update
so stay tuned
version 11 will add four new monsters
we've already revealed lucent marga kuga
and seething basildis
but today we also revealed silver
rathalops and gold rather
these monsters will become available
after you reach master rank
10. last time we saw lucent narghakuga
was in monster hunter tri ultimate in
2013.
so it's been a while
it lives in a new local that we're
adding in the update the forlorn arena
its distinguishing feature is that it
can use its bright white fur to refract
moonlight allowing it to become
invisible
speaking of becoming visible camillios
has a similar characteristic
but
is much more agile
and the trails left by its red eyes in
the darkness and the fog are a true
sight to behold
in terms of visuals the designers took
great care to preserve the atmosphere of
the original locale
while adding new elements and
interpretations to the ambience and
background among other things
seething basil geese contrary to the
regular basil geese has explosive scales
that are constantly active making it
much more dangerous
it can even go into an extra powerful
state where it sees with even more rage
at which point it will start showering
the area with critically volatile scales
[Music]
they can go into a powerful incandescent
state where they start attacking even
more ferociously
we've given them some new moves for
sunbury so we think you'll find them
quite challenging
the armor you can forge from the
materials of the monsters added in
version 11 all come included with new
skills as well so you have even more
customization options
some of you may already be playing this
but i'd like to do a quick breakdown of
anomaly quests
which are a new addition to sun break
after you've completed the story in
monster hunter rise sun break and raise
your master rank to 10 you'll be able to
take on new quests called anomaly quests
anomaly quests are quests where you take
on monsters that have been afflicted by
the creatures malzaina once controlled
the curio
causing them to go into an ultra violent
rage
as your master rank increases you'll
gradually unlock more monsters to hunt
in anomaly quests
in the current version of the game
version 10 you can play anomaly quests
up to a4 star rank
by completing a certain quest at master
rank 50 or higher
you can use the unique materials gained
from anomaly quests
to upgrade your weapons to rarity 10.
this is the way the system involving
afflicted monsters currently works in
version 10.
[Music]
starting from title update version 11
the quest surrounding afflicted monsters
will greatly expand
we've added four new elements for
hunters who are looking for something to
sink their teeth into
first let's start with the regular
anomaly quests
with the addition of a5 star rank
anomaly quests you'll be able to take on
new afflicted monsters such as luna
guerin and magma almadron
a5 star monsters will be unlocked
through anomaly investigations of which
i will tell you more about in a moment
so we hope you give them a go
the beefiest new addition to this update
are anomaly investigations
anomaly investigations have a set level
and as that level increases the monsters
become gradually stronger and the
rewards you can earn will change
the quest conditions like the target
monster locale and number of players are
all decided at random
[Music]
and you can earn special materials for
completing these investigations that
open up new upgrades for your weapons
and armor
the materials you earn from anomaly
investigations
can be used for adding new upgrades to
your equipment
pick a stat you want to upgrade like
attack power or affinity
then pick a combination to upgrade your
gear
armor can be upgraded with random
improvements to stats like defense
resistance and skill points
i hope you will try out these
investigations
to create gear that matches your
personal play style
in the new anomaly research lab opened
by bahati the scientist
you'll be able to exchange the items you
gained from anomaly investigations for
items that are useful for curious
crafting
that's anomaly investigations
the quest ranks and monsters that appear
for anomaly quests as well as the level
cap for anomaly investigations will be
expanded with every new title update
here's some more information on other
updates
for more details please visit our
official website and social media
after update version 11
we will start releasing event quests
kicking off on august 18th
we plan to have new event quests every
week with a variety of conditions so we
hope you look forward to them
more information on event quests will be
made available on our official website
and social media
we are also introducing some extra
difficult event quests
known as dual threats which require you
to hunt two monsters like silver
rathalos and gold wrathion at the same
time
try these if you're looking for a solid
challenge
quests can be claimed by going to the
courier at your base and selecting
add-on content
[Music]
after update version 11 we will also
start selling new dlc
[Music]
for instance we will be adding layered
armor
that makes your character look exactly
like certain npcs
you can equip the fear rain layered
armor to make your character look
exactly like her including all of her
features
regardless of which body type you choose
for your character
we will also sell fear reigns voice as a
dlc on the same day so you can turn your
character entirely into her
no task is too great for me
we'll have other layered armor for your
hunter and your buddies as well
on top of gestures stickers
and piano versions of the bgm like what
you're hearing now
you can access the nintendo eshop via
the title screen or the courier at your
base
[Music]
if you're planning on purchasing monster
hunter rise sun break here's some more
info
if you already own monster hunter rides
and just want to buy sun break
all you have to do is buy the digital
version of monster hunter rise sunbreak
if you do not own monster hunter rise
yet
you can purchase the monster hunter ryze
plus sun break set to get both games at
once
the various new elements added to sun
break can be accessed
by completing the seven star hub quest
serpent goddess of thunder
if you're completely new to ryze you can
claim the support armor black belt s set
for free which will help you get through
low and high rank quests
we've also added new upgrade trees for
the 14 defender weapons
so make sure to check those out too
to recap the free title update monster
hunter rise sun break version 11.
will be released on august 10th
we also have title update 2 in store for
you
which is scheduled for the end of
september
we're currently working on even more
free updates too
thank you for tuning in to the monster
hunter rise sun break special program
see you next time
happy
hunting
[Music]
[Music]
you